abuela abuela aoc's
abuela she doesn't call her grandma she
calls her abuela
i don't refer to my grandmother as but
aoc to make a point about how much she
doesn't like america
insists on using these kind of borrowed
words every now and again
she says that abuela's roof in puerto
rico
is in disrepair aoc who is wealthy and
drives a tesla
refuses to help abuela but she's angry
and she's going to criticize donald
trump for not helping abuela even though
donald trump actually did help abuela
but corrupt puerto rican politicians
took the money
so matt walsh a true philanthropist at
the daily wire
put up a gofundme campaign and he said
we got to help abuela
raise money to fix a roof the campaign
raised over a hundred thousand dollars
in about 10 hours
i donated okay look i know i know i'm a
philanthropist i don't know what to tell
we all
a lot of conservatives donated now
part of this is i think a lot of
conservatives knew aoc wouldn't
wouldn't permit the money to be taken
and you think that's that's exactly what
happened actually
first of all i think a lot of
conservatives gave and just thought like
okay this lady needs a roof fund
what's it to me i'm i'm i like that i
like being charitable
but a lot of us also knew aoc wouldn't
take the money
because aoc hates private charity in the
same way that bernie sanders hates
private charity i
i talk about this is philosophically
consistent with leftism i talk about
this in my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling mines
which is available now
for pre-order and you can get a signed
first edition copy premiere collectibles
so
matt gets a letter from gofundme you're
matt we're in touch with the
beneficiary's family
and they've made clear they will not be
accepting the funds raised and so now we
all get a refund
my question is does
does the family of a beneficiary get to
make that decision
because we didn't we didn't start this
gofundme
for aoc to dole out as she pleases to
abuela
the gofundme was for abuela so really
abuela should be making this decision as
far as i know aoc doesn't have power of
attorney over abuela but
someone in the family someone powerful
enough in the family to get go
i wonder who that could be goes in and
says kill this thing we don't
we would rather abuela's roof be broken
than accept
a hundred grand from conservatives
because that would prove
that they're right and we're wrong and
that they're
doing a good thing and we're big jerks
about it so they
they turn it down i think someone needs
to investigate this i don't think
that aoc or anyone else in that family
has the right to do this to abuela
seems very wrong to me stop stop
don't go you see i'm waving the flag of
the french army here to get your
attention
you've got to subscribe you got to ring
that bell you got to like you got to
make sure you get the notifications for
these videos because big tech
doesn't always want that to happen you
can also head on over to apple podcast
google play stitcher
spotify aol instant messenger all over
the place netscape
to get the audio podcast please leave a
five-star review we really appreciate it
we'll see you next time